so hi everyone uh
this is conrad i'm one of the co-chairs
for the pi data global conference this
year uh we're super
happy to welcome tariq
for this uh experts briefings talk uh
tariq has been working as a data
scientist for over 25 years tariq thank
you take it away
fantastic well thanks for the
introduction and um and thanks everyone
else for joining in um i'm really
looking forward to having a discussion
so what i want to
do today is just spend maybe 10 minutes
giving an overview of
a brief history of regulation around
data and
and algorithms and where that's headed
in terms of regulation that's expected
to land in the coming years
i want to just touch on some of the main
concepts because they're useful for us
to understand no matter where we are
working in the world
but then after that brief kind of
overview i want to have a group
discussion with
a project which is taken from a real
life project with the names removed and
simplified a little bit and what i want
us to do is for us to have a an active
discussion around how we would do that
project what the risks are how we would
mitigate those and the idea is that this
isn't some kind of um test or anything
it's it's where we can raise questions
that really bother us or where we can
learn from each other so no question is
too trivial and it's a really nice forum
for asking those things that you always
wanted to because we're amongst friends
so i that's that's my aim uh to do that
um just a small tiny correction i
haven't been a data scientist for 25
years i've been involved in data daytime
technology for 25 years
i do have a background i guess in
machine learning data mining and i've
worked in sectors which are fairly
regulated for example a decade in
central government developing
services which people use and some of
those services if you don't get them
right people are impacted and that's why
we care about um
designing services and how they are
developed and governed care about
getting that right
so i'll try and share my screen great
can everyone see one just one page of
slide
yep yeah great okay
so um as i said i'll give you a quick uh
quick overview of where we've been and
where we're likely headed and some of
the main themes and concepts that are in
in that regulation
and i'll talk very quickly about um some
of the lessons i've learned
in um
in
in in how
organizations do data science projects
how they get them right how they get
them wrong i won't dive into it too
deeply because the discussion is the
main point
so certainly in the uk and in europe
we have the main regulation which is the
gdpr and its primary focus is about
protecting
the
security of data primarily it talks
about accuracy it talks about
transparency it also talks about a right
to understand how data is processed and
used but when this legislation was
designed
there wasn't such a big industry around
algorithmic use of data the focus is
very much on protecting it so that's the
history
over the last few years governments
around the world the u.s
countries in europe
in the east and certainly in the uk have
been consulting and
developing
frameworks for thinking about
how to assess the quality of uh
an algorithm which is driven by data
and where the algorithm is is
sophisticated or complicated
which makes its which makes
understanding how it works non-trivial
um and that has led to a lot of you know
debate around ethics around um
transparency around legality and this
has been a very healthy debate one of
the nice things around this
discussion and activity
is the surprising level of
agreement and consensus
around the world whether it's the u.s
whether it's
asia whether it's europe and including
the uk which is nice because it means
that when these discussions and
consultations and emerging frameworks
become regulation they're likely to be
aligned there's likely to be not
significant um
divergence in terms of kind of
philosophy
and so that's a nice thing and it means
business
and you know interoperability across
borders will be a little bit easier
certainly in europe um they they are a
little bit ahead of where we are in the
uk and they've been working quite hard
and have just recently published
proposals for
um
the the what's called the ai act
and that's around regulating
sophisticated algorithms
quotes ai and that's likely to land
towards the end of next year
as a precursor to that
they've published a couple of years ago
i think it was
the ethics guidelines for trustworthy ai
it's a very short document but it was
very popular because it was very clear
and it explained the rationale behind
the objectives
and the rational now can be drawn back
to human rights essentially and there is
such a clear document it became popular
and versions of it were taken
by other industries so if you let some
of the private sector organizations
their own
internal guidance is based on that so if
you only look at one document i'd look
at that one and it's 37 pages long and
it's very very clear and it sets you up
in good stead
the ai act itself has some um
controversial elements to it um which
hopefully will be ironed out between now
and
and when it lands next year
for example um prohibition on
facial recognition in real time so
there's immediately then a question of
what does real time mean and what does
not real time mean so there's some some
terminology and uh
issues to be dealt with there
just a bit of a timeline to give you an
idea of how fast things are moving gdpr
it was landed 2016
the the the popular
guidelines for trustworthy ai landed in
2019 uh the proposed regulations for ai
act in europe 2021 expected to be live
in 2022
um now the concepts are i think really
important to understand because those
are the ones we can apply to our own
projects so the gdpr had seven and none
of them will surprise us
it talks about things that you know like
accountability accuracy of the data
integrity and confidentiality security
lawful purposes for having data
transparency around what data you hold
and letting people know uh what data you
hold about them and also broader themes
like aiming for limitation of data that
you collect enough for
the uh the purpose that that you need it
for
um
so this those are useful concepts um but
as we said gdpr was mostly aimed at
protecting data and it wasn't as
concerned at around how we use data
there are some of the examples of some
of the frameworks that have been merged
over the last few years and as i've said
the eu ethics guidelines for trust with
the ai if you only look at one that's
the one to to look at
and as i said
the versions of that
branches if you if you talk about if you
like github speak uh
you ought to be found in other sectors
now the ethics guidelines and set out
seven pillars um
which are
are useful to act as prisms to look
through at your own projects
and again they're not surprising but
they are fairly complete so it's a
useful
conceptual model to have
accountability in governance we'll talk
about these later as we when we grapple
with a real project
technical robustness and safety now
i have to say when i'm talking to
python developers data scientists who
are very technological in background and
love working with data and writing code
and building systems their focus
naturally is on technical robustness on
accuracy on performance on on kind of
measurable kind of bias and variation
and so on and that's totally
understandable but from a project's
perspective from an organization's
perspective you have to get other things
right like governance
like understanding the legal basis on
which we have access to training data
whether we can use data collected for
one purpose elsewhere
concepts like
human agency and oversight so the eu
derives its frameworks
and the grounds them in human rights
and and protecting in the quality of
life of individuals it has a political
vision for that and
that's that's something that you can
agree or disagree with
and and it believes that
particularly uh over
um decisions that affect you are
life-changing
we should have human agency you should
be able to
reverse or appeal or
go back against those decisions and say
look i disagree with this it needs to be
looked at again so there's no avoids the
tyranny of automated decisions about
about you
some decisions are such so
risky or have such high impact that they
require um
quite close human sign-off so these are
concepts that are embedded
in that framework
um
some some of the techniques have
developed in machine learning are quite
energy intensive so we have to think a
little bit about do we want to use this
much energy do we want to burn through
this many trees
does it match the purpose that we are
putting the algorithm to
very quickly i'll say the regulation
it's a it's a regulation not a directive
so it's it's it's a legal um um
is legally applicable in all 27
countries they don't interpret it they
they enact it
um
and and very similar to the gdpr it has
fines
so it has teeth
[Music]
and it's extra territorial what that
means is it applies to eu citizens even
if the services they use are not based
in the eu and one of the effects that
has like the gdpr is that it has the
effect of
spreading and harmonizing
these high standards
around the world and that's seen by some
of us is very positive
you can't ignore a market of 450 million
or a sixth of the world economy
as i said earlier the concept the
philosophy behind the the eu's framework
is human rights and that and i said it's
worth kind of reading uh the text on
that because it's easy to read and it
explains why it arises at certain uh
objectives and controls
so the um
the the proposed regulation um
defines four areas of risk it's driven
by risk what it says is that
our response to um a project an ai
project or a data-driven project
is driven primarily by the impact of it
going wrong so the first step is to
understand what is the risk and it
defines four categories at this stage
and it's just worth briefly having a
rough idea of what they are
unacceptable risk is is prohibited
so things like using subliminal
techniques to alter people's behavior
without them knowing you're doing that
that's clearly unethical and is
prohibited
social scoring by governments again that
is uh prohibited and there are some
exceptions um
around
military um and uh
police law law and order with exceptions
that are time-bound for example if
there's an ongoing incident or
somebody's been kidnapped you can use
techniques which are normally not
allowed
high risk of the top right is where most
of our interesting work is medical
equipment financial services public
services self-driving cars
these kinds of services um
because because those are the things
that if you get them right have a
positive impact if you get them wrong
you can you can hurt people so a lot of
our
work will be in that top right space but
it's also interesting to understand what
the other two remaining categories are
so we can put them aside and calibrate
what we mean by high risk so limited
risk is where you know there's not you
know if you're selling flowers and you
recommend the wrong flower it's not
gonna really really hurt anyone too much
um but transparency is still required
and minimal risk is things like video
game ir or spam filters where you know
it really doesn't matter too much if it
goes wrong it might be annoyed that the
games have got a glitch or it's not
behaving as you'd expect
so what does the high risk entail what's
the response to a project that falls
into that category
again you shouldn't be surprised it's
it's asking for a risk assessments it's
asking that you understand the data sets
that you use to train your algorithm
it says high quality but really we need
to think about what is sufficient
quality
are the date is the data kept up to date
does it match a shift and
drift in the source from where we're
deriving that data does it match
the any drifts or changes in where we're
applying it
auditability traceability
reproducibility if you end up in court
and have to explain how you arrived at
your algorithm you need to be able to
have an evidence trail for that you know
lots of startups are very keen on
producing things that work but don't so
focus so much on on keeping records and
not just records of meetings but keeping
data sets and parameters
that you used along your journey you
know in a form that you can say right
this is evidential this is what we did
um
i won't read the rest of it but you you
can later
uh just say a few words just a few
lessons that i've learned in working
with organizations around things that
sometimes go wrong when they implement a
project
the first thing i think to say is that
they should really start with
understanding what the responsibilities
are first
and then assigning them to
people and that can mean people that
they already exist or people have to
bring in what i often see is
someone has to do the user reset someone
has to
check the buyer somebody else has to
make sure their records are capital date
and and you miss uh responsibilities by
by by doing it that way around so i see
this happening a lot which is why i've
highlighted it
the other uh main
point that i've seen go wrong sometimes
is the top of the organization needs to
understand that its investment in a
project
has to be proportionate to the risk
so often the organization whether it's a
startup or a large enterprise gets very
excited about the possibility of
interesting algorithms and machine
learning and ai and using data and
imagines all kinds of wonderful insights
and outcomes
but it doesn't think enough about well
what if it goes wrong
and that is what drives a business case
for the investment in these activities
to get the safety
right to make sure that you invest in
testing that you invest in the research
around the data they invest in feedback
loops which help you catch when things
have started to drift or to go wrong so
that's the really important thing that i
see go wrong they find they can't afford
to do the right things because they
haven't invested and the case wasn't
made based on actual impact
so it's like security you start with a
description of how bad can it get and
that drives um the investment
don't start with the data scientist
sorry to say that at this conference
as much as we love start with
accountability an owner
who understands it's their
responsibility and their accountability
if things go wrong
if you don't get that right
then you can't
um make the right decisions well
sometimes decisions are resisted
so you have to get that clarity somebody
has to say
this is the person that owns the risk
once you've done that again no data
sciences just yet do the user research
understand what problem that you it is
that you're trying to solve because
sometimes we are driven by our
enthusiasm for technology and and
algorithms and some of the cool
libraries and and we want to build
something that's cool but it doesn't
necessarily match what would work for
the users so as cool as it is if it
doesn't work for users
there's there's we're losing value or
we're wasting we're wasting resources
and then we we develop and iterate with
uh close feedback loops from from
testing this is something i think most
people in this conference are familiar
with
and the other thing i keep seeing going
wrong is the lack of a feedback loop
not just from testing but from your
users
there's no point in developing something
which can't learn it's not just your
algorithm that's learning it's your team
your project your your service has to
learn when it's going wrong so if your
organization is not open
and receptive to citizens users
customers
telling you that something's not right
if then it's not going to learn
and so you need that sensor out there
and it needs to be responsive and that
process needs to be painless
it can't be a defensive bureaucratic
wall that's put up
that's really important and some of the
things that do go wrong
happen as a result of that
um i'll stop talking there that was just
to kind of see the discussion in a real
bit um what i'll do before i go back to
the kind of discussion room is
is to kind of paint a picture of a
project which is based on a real world
project uh in fact there's probably many
of these and what i'll do is i'll
describe its mission
but i won't give too many details
because i want our discussion to fill in
some of the
gaps or to say well where's this and
what about this i i think that active
discussion is where we learn most and
where we kind of you know have a
meaningful discussion so
very briefly
our project is to provide banks
with a better risk assessment credit
score
for people who are
uh perhaps vulnerable perhaps they're
homeless
so that's a vague statement deliberately
um so that's the mission
this is your project whether you're a
startup or a or a team within a large
organization
and we're going to talk about well how
do we go about doing this what are the
risks uh what how do we control risks
what does ethics mean and any other
questions you want to uh raise
so i'll go back to stop sharing that
i hope that was um a a useful
thought-provoking introduction just to
get the discussion going so um so let me
ask the question to the group actually
i'm sorry this is a guided discussion so
i'll i'll ask questions so
um
if we are developing uh a system
to provide uh banks with a a score
around
uh credit risk um
we have to
use some information to feed that
where can we get that information from
if the users are
as we've designed here
homeless
what information can we use and then we
can talk about whether that's feasibly
obtainable whether it's ethical and so
on what information can we use
any thoughts or ideas remember they some
of these uh people will not have bank
accounts perhaps
um
some of them won't have credit cards so
there's no credit history and any
thoughts around that
i think somebody's raised their hand do
you want to i
want to yeah
it's like when you say uh homelessness
do you uh can you specify what you mean
by like do you think means something
like digital nomad where they definitely
don't have a permanent resonance um or
are you talking about homelessness in
the sense of like uh being destitute and
being forced to live on a street against
your will
so that's a really good question and the
reason that's a good question is because
what you've identified is
two different sets of circumstances
which can lead to somebody not having a
a a
residence or an address in the
traditional sense
so you can have individuals who are
nomadic perhaps
and therefore and and you know perhaps
have you know great jobs and income and
so on they just happen not to reside
anywhere for more than say six months
but there's nothing intrinsically risky
around
offering them financial products
so that's that's a great insight into
understanding well you know
let's understand why people might not
have a data point such as an address
longer than six months
and then there's a second category which
you said where people are involuntarily
without a home so they perhaps having to
sleep in shelters or on the street so
already you've asked good questions
around let's understand our users
if we say that
the bank's traditionally use
um a home address as an indicator of
stability
we've identified a a scenario where
actually these users these individuals
could be good customers but there are
valid reasons why they don't
so so you've you this theme around
researching
uh your users lifestyles understanding
their circumstances is really important
and and those assumptions around why
people might not have say for example a
long-term home address uh can be kind of
broken down into
several valid reasons so that's a great
great point there
is it manages is that how i pronounce
that right
manage it fantastic
so that's a that's that's a great
question um another question is um
should banks be using um
a a long-term residence
address as a as a key indicator because
they do at the moment many banks do so
we could say as a project
actually um that has nothing to do with
um uh the
individual's risk around around credit
products there are other better metrics
so that's a valid question to ask
alright as well
so all these questions around
challenging assumptions should be done
at the early research stage and the more
of these kinds of questions we can have
the more likely to find a solution that
advances beyond what what the
traditional financial institutions are
doing
i think there's a question from ali i
think
yeah i just want to chip in a little bit
i mean this is a very challenging task
you know
trying to come up with a
credit score for homeless people you
know you need data
to be able to do that
and to your point about using a
long-term residence address yeah maybe
banks shouldn't do that but
they will need to be able to contact
these people
so some address will be necessary
to that point and for initial data
collection maybe a collaboration with
shelters might be useful
you know to be able to collect some data
around this topic
yep
excellent points um and you're
absolutely right to say
banks will need some data
and you're right to challenge the need
for the particular data point around
residence address
uh some way of contacting users so
if we've done our research right we
might find
that
people even if they don't have a home
address they would likely have a phone
or an email address or or
an sms way of getting a phone number to
get to them and and certainly in the uk
some of the charities will provide
people with a telephone so they can
access basic services so already that
realizing that gives us an advantage
a point on which to progress beyond the
the traditional um method so
if we are going to um
uh focus on say a subset of of users so
not the ones who are nomads
but people who
[Music]
happen to be homeless at the moment
don't have
significant income
or maybe they do
they're homeless but they might have
some income
um because they work perhaps um
as well as
room need to use a shelter so that's one
category
um
what kind of
information do you think we can use
to convince a bank
that this individual
is
safe to give a credit card to
what kind of information do you think is
useful
that that somebody in those
circumstances will they'll have that
data
so so one example is the individual will
be needing to
purchase things
you know buy food
clothes even if that money isn't
necessarily theirs they might earn it or
they might be given some support
so there is a spending history which
isn't necessarily
credit history in terms of taking a loan
and paying it back it's actual debit
history so they're buying things
perhaps that can be used as an indicator
of
risk so if somebody's buying food
but not buying and i apologize for
this example if somebody's not spending
um the support money they get on say
champagne or stereos or cars
is there something in there that we can
use
i'll leave that out for a discussion
there
are there
is a val is there some is there a
concept of valid good spend versus valid
bad spend
what do people think
uh i think he definitely there i think
there's a lot of assumptions there um
and possibly uh you know i'm gonna
propose that maybe like uh you can just
let the data speak and see if you know
buying a lot of like basic necessities
make people a better uh
a better creditor versus
versus you know if you're buying a
stereo
and we can just you know sort of based
on past experiences
try to decide that
okay so so that's a really interesting
rich seem a rich avenue to go down
so the idea there i'm being deliberately
controversial by the way
so if we say yes if somebody is having
to buy food and buying food um but is
avoiding um buying say champagne or or
things like that
does that make them a better customer
so there's immediately there's questions
around
um
stereotyping
there's questions around judgment on how
people live their lives
there's questions around
um
well maybe they bought a birthday
present for somebody which was champagne
um
maybe somebody's spending more than they
have
but it could be that they have a child
that they need to feed no matter what
because there is no option not to feed
the child
um
so so what does this tell us it tells us
two things
one
that actually the circumstances of this
user group
are rich and varied and there are lots
and lots of different
scenarios which need to be considered
it's a much bigger problem
than simply saying let's set up a data
science team feed them the bank account
details and get them to correlate
long-term debt or you know judgments
against them with
i don't know
codes that enumerate the things they buy
we could do that and we can end up with
a model that works but what we've missed
is
insights into what valid reasons why
people might be spending
um so it's really it's really
complicated so this is definitely a can
of worms that we've we've opened the
second point um conrad that you've
highlighted which i was hoping that we
would get into in which we have through
your question
is this idea of judgment
this idea of who decides what is
okay for somebody to spend money on uh
who says it's okay for somebody to have
this kind of lifestyle and the important
point i want to make there is
those are really difficult questions and
often there is no objective mathematical
scientific answer
the answer lies in
and this is a difficult conclusion for
many people the answer lies in your own
values
so if you're an organization a startup a
developer
your values will be infused into the
code that you write the algorithms that
you develop the research that you decide
not to do or to do
now that's something we can't get away
from so how do we deal with that
and we're all learning to do this is as
an industry this is new
but what has worked for me and the
people that i've kind of helped work
with
is asking them encouraging them to say
can you stand up in public
and explain
why you've made those value judgments
if you can defend that to
the public in which you operate
then you're probably on the right track
you might get some controversy but if
you can't do that you're doing something
wrong
i'll stop talking there because i think
some questions have come in i think um
ali you had a question and there's a
question in the chat so ali you raised
your hand here just earlier
yeah um not a question actually but
some idea about the initial data
collection um
yes some people may not have bank
accounts but bank accounts are not
necessarily the only way to collect
payment and you know make payments to
whatever for example applications like
venmo in us
allows you to make payments and collect
payments with your cell phone
and to your point you said um
homeless people
may have some
cell phones um
even if they don't have an address so
that might be a way to collect some data
yep
yeah
absolutely um and your earlier point
around using shelters to gain some
insight
and to connect with um vulnerable
individuals is a really important one
because we have to look after the
welfare of of our users
if they're taking part in in testing if
we're doing research
they will know better than the
technology team that we have
working in our own organization so again
so it's interesting isn't it there's a
there's a maxim there's a
kind of a slogan or a meme that says 80
of data science is cleaning data we all
laugh and juggle at that
well actually at a project level you
know i'm saying that actually maybe 80
or 60 percent of our work is in
understanding
users and their and their lifestyles and
their circumstances in which they live
and understand understanding that
particularly
when the products that we are designing
can be life affecting if we get them
wrong
um so that there's an interesting
parallel there let's move this
discussion forward a little bit um so i
don't want to under emphasize the
importance of of user research and
understanding your users it's huge and
and we should proportionately
give it a lot of attention but let's for
the sake of this exercise move forward
to say let's say we have some data now
around uh people spending uh because
that's all they have released they go
into the supermarkets and they they buy
things and they don't have a credit card
they buy it on david and we've gained
agreement for example that we can have
access to their bank account so we can
have a feed of of spending data
um now one of the questions that pops up
in organizations is
we can have very simple models
um you know regression something like
this
um
for deciding whether somebody is a risk
or not or it's kind of decision tree or
we can have something very much more
complicated like a very deep
neural network which is fed lots of
features and in a data's inputs and it
produces an output
and it seems to produce something that
is
quite performant against the test data
that we're using
but we can't explain it
or not easily
so this could this question of the black
box
so some people will say
um you should not and and some people
who are working in you know policy and
government space will say we should not
use black box algorithms
for um
uh automating decisions that affect
people's livelihoods
now that's an open question um different
people have a different stance on that
different governments will have a
different stance on that what are the
thoughts around the table so i'll set
the question again
we have a black box algorithm like a
very deep neural network we're feeding
it lots of information that we haven't
really thought about we're just throwing
it all at it
and it seems to perform better than the
decision tree that we can derive
now do we use it
or not
there's lots of missing information
there but i want to just encourage some
debate there
what are people's thoughts around that
okay
so
i'm not going to say there's a right or
wrong answer here
um but what i will say is
we have black box
systems in other sectors
so if we look at medicine for example
the effect of medication is not 100
deterministic
and the individuals into which those
that medication goes
is varied and people have different uh
physiologies and react differently to
medication
so we can't always say why
um there are side effects in some people
and why medicine doesn't work or has a
catastrophic effect
so the approach that has been refined
over hundreds of years
not not tens of years or even months
hundreds of years is this concept of
broad testing
uh really having a systematic approach
to
and
and defining
what kinds of individuals you test
medication on
understanding what amount of testing is
sufficient to achieve a level of
confidence
um
having independent you know assessment
of that testing process so that we are
able to approve medicines
where we can't always explain why
they do or don't work in some
individuals and might have a
catastrophic effect
but we can say with statistical
significance that say you know 98 of the
time there's no negative effect 70 of
the time it has it works and in two
percent it has a very negative effect
so we do that in other sectors
yeah we should be able to apply that
thinking um in in terms of the
application of of so-called black box
algorithms so we can say empirically
that it performs to ascend level
we can say statistically that it works
you know in 98 of cases tested on 20 000
people so the question translates into
not yes or no
but a question of when and how can we
achieve
assurance satisfaction that it's safe
enough and that will depend on different
contexts so what i'm doing is is
encouraging you to move away from yes no
to you know can this be made to work can
we achieve um satisfaction
was there a question there did somebody
raise their hand i thought somebody did
uh i just thought a random random
thought on this uh i think the
government
and uh certain sectors i think it makes
a lot more sense
uh for them to not have a black box and
have sort of more of a decision tree or
some sort of
uh factor-based model simply because uh
it allows
uh
people or uh people to adjust right so
it allows uh you know somebody to appeal
the decision and say
uh hey you know what like i was
disqualified for this reason
um
you know like like like here's my
current situation
uh you know like maybe uh just using
eminel's example right like uh you know
i was spending a lot on this uh which
disqualified me but you know here's my
medical reason for it right uh and and
it allows like a manual override right
which which i think is valuable in
uh yeah in certain cases where like you
do need to take into account um
the ethical considerations are a lot
higher right
yeah
absolutely i think that's a really good
point and in some sectors
or in some scenarios we might value that
so so that might be a legal requirement
so some sectors there is a legal
requirement for explainability and
recourse
in others there isn't necessarily there
but we might decide that we value
an explainable model and an adjustable
model
over something that appears to perform a
few percent better but we don't know why
it performs
at that at that level so again that's a
really valuable discussion and in the
more mature organizations that i've
helped
that's where the discussion ends up and
they have that discussion to say we as
an organization value
the ability to explain
and to kind of correct or adjust
um over
just just just the output but in other
sectors you know where the ability to
kind of
retrace those steps you know if you've
got a game engine you might not you
might not care you know it doesn't
really matter so again it's defense and
such that's a really really good good
point sometimes we don't have a have a
choice so i think in the uk in the
finance sector you have to be able to
explain those decisions
um which which is quite a strong kind of
strong requirement the um
the financial conduct authority runs the
scheme
uh where they have a regulatory sandbox
and they encourage companies to try
different ideas which apparently go
against current policy but they're open
to exploring the benefits of
you know things like black bloc
algorithms if the benedictive is
significantly there
it's an opportunity for them to think
about well how do we adjust uh
regulations to kind of enable that
because we want to benefit from from
some of the advanced techniques that we
you have been developing
um are there any questions that anyone
wants to ask that we haven't discussed
or where the discussion has gone one way
but you would like to kind of ask a
question that's in a different direction
um is there any question that people
want to or any kind of direction that
people want to
to go in this discussion
um so i have a random thought uh sure
so uh
there is so so going back to sort of the
explainable uh stuff uh with factors
versus uh black box stuff um so for
example explainable stuff if you know
what all the factors are uh there is the
possibility to gain the system right to
just sort of like you know
have everything fit exactly uh there
right but also
i i don't think this has happened
as as much yet just because i don't
think like uh the models will ride
widespread yet but for you know even
even for a black box thing uh you can
have some sort of like adversarial like
uh
adversary example right
in which case uh it's probably gonna be
even harder
to detect
if you're gaming the system or not right
because
uh
because in that case it's it's uh like
it's it's probably not even going to
show up as a
abnormality right
um
so uh yeah i'm just
curious uh yeah really
which is really interesting yeah i know
it's really interesting um
so as the sophistication of some of
these mods increases
the ability to detect
fraudulent inputs
or inputs that try to gain game system
um you know is it gets quite hard
i think the way to think about it
certainly in in my opinion that
different different pins are valid is
you know
people sometimes can get into a moral
panic about some of these failure modes
and there are lots of failure modes um
and and there's
let me take a step back and say
what are the things that when discussing
issues like this one of the things
that's really helped me is
learning from parallel disciplines like
information security so if we're saying
information security there's some really
obscure vulnerabilities that could be
exploited
and some people get very excited
enthused by that
the approach in that more mature field
that has developed around dealing with
those things is to say
what is at stake what is what is it what
can what is the impact of that being
exploited so what's the impact of an
adversarial example
what's the scale of it so if one person
out of 20 million
manages to get a mortgage that they
shouldn't have got
and they spend two months trying to work
out what the right weights and inputs
are
do we want to counter that is it worth
the effort to
counter that are we going to spend
5 million on development and testing
for somebody who spent 150 000 pounds on
a home they shouldn't have so there's an
issue there's an issue of balance there
um
yeah so so i think taking that kind of
risk-based approach to say well you know
what is the impact do we care about this
risk is it worth the investment to
mitigate against it um is is is the
right approach and again you know these
are these are questions for the team and
and the project in the organization
not just necessarily a technical
developer but the technical developers
are valuable because they have the
insights into the specifics of these
these kind of vulnerabilities um it's a
growing field it's really interesting
you know the the the uh the
vulnerabilities of of of sophisticated
uh ai models um i think that i predict
they'll become a discipline and a job
spec in itself uh people who can who can
kind of poke them and and do the
equivalent of pen testing or red teaming
on these things um then a really really
really fascinating point
okay let's let's move on to a kind of a
final theme um
so there's a big debate around whether
um
regulation will be
a counter to innovation it will slow
down innovation
it um it stops companies experimenting
and building useful services
um and and the uk at the moment seems to
be heading in the trajectory of
uh less regulation of being more
pro-business whereas other countries
perhaps like the eu are um heading in
the more kind of cautious approach
what what do people think here see i
guess most people do work in this day
today
what are people's thoughts on where
where that sh you know where where the
right regulation should be
there's a question in the chat which
says any thoughts on how to be more
systematic when it comes to the
responsible use of ai
yeah so um i think that the the broad
picture is that this is a new field and
good practice and patterns for doing
this are emerging
so the reason when you speak to people
who do this
they don't have you know a reference
book or a or a clear-cut answer is
because
we need to work a few more years for
good practice to emerge and for the
regulation to land because that will
shape how we work it will define roles
for example
um
the the best answer i can give you at
the moment is to
mirror what we do in information
security where we start with a risk
assessment we as we map out what data
what systems which users
and we and we kind of
estimate the risks
and then we try to control them we have
we should parallel and mirror the
concept of having a senior risk owner so
that somebody
really feels the
incentive the pressure their
responsibility to make sure these
questions are addressed and raised
and invested in
you know too often we ask these
questions but there's no investment
there's no investment because the
organization doesn't understand that
this is a risk to the business so i
think if you're starting from nowhere or
if you're starting in the if you're at
the start of that kind of journey
there are good practices from
information security i think where we'd
expand on information security is what
we talked about at the start of this
debate which is
more focused on understanding the user's
context their life the reasons they
might behave in certain ways
that is a lot more pronounced those
factors than
um some of the information security
challenges that we might face so that
that's that i i would i respond to your
question in that way
great so i'm conscious of time that
we're coming up to an hour um any last
questions or thoughts or
um yeah there's a question there is it
rishama is that right
uh yes it's rishma
rish mahaya
um so um building on what you said
earlier i come from a background of
working on clinical trials and so it is
very very highly regulated um
you know and so um you know that is
something that could be brought into
ai and um
you know data in general um
it's there seems to be enough
documentation out there about the times
when um
you know ai is
failing all the algorithms are failing
and the problems that they're causing
but there seems to be no recourse on how
to do it you know we just see it being
you know reported in the news maybe
there's some lawsuits here and there but
to um
you know regulation just like that would
help
thank you that's a really useful insight
from from from the medical sector and
i
you're absolutely right you know we do
too often hear about failures where
there hasn't been the ability to have
recourse
i'm not as aware as what's happening in
the us but certainly in germany there's
a lot of work going on around
how to use
ai's type algorithms in medical
scenarios
and again it's very regulated but
they've done a lot of
work in standardizing
some of some of the kind of
measures and
the kind of assessments you would do
the big challenge that the medical
sector faces or certainly medical
equipment
is that
a lot of medical equipment and medical
systems
are designed and tested
in a static context
they will work in this context and then
they're not adapted or changed they're
not expected to change
whereas
with um with machine learning and ai
systems
often the these characteristics of input
data will change
the
the scenarios in which they're applied
will be varied so the emergent the
challenge to that sector has been how do
we
certify something which is likely to be
updated next month next year and the
years after that and that adaptability
for some sectors is easy but from from
my experience uh the the kind of the
medical uh sector has found that uh
adaptive updating of certifications
quite quite difficult it also actually
happens that to be the case in um
defense as well where
some of those systems are very highly
assured
but the assurance context is static
and if you're developing systems that
are adaptive and learn
that's where their value is
the ability to
update a certification
is um is is is a cultural challenge not
a technical challenge but a cultural
challenge
rishma you wanted to come back in
yeah just one more thing that we often
hear and i think is that always keeping
a human in the loop
is um you know
not having 100 of the decisions
allocated to an algorithm that having a
human in the loop along somewhere along
the process um would help
yeah
very very good point and certainly you
know from from the eu's
regulatory approach that's really
important and emphasized
my response to that would be again it
depends on the impact so you start from
your your picture of risk
and and it may because human people are
expensive so you may be there for some
scenarios you don't need to do that
for some of the lower impact scenarios
for some higher impact scenarios you do
need to do that and the investment makes
sense but what's interesting is what
sits in between
and i've been helping a few clients at
the moment find that balance where it's
not one or the other extreme it's in the
middle
where you benefit from the velocity and
scale of an algorithm
for 80 percent or 90 of your
use cases the data that's coming in
but what you do is you design an
algorithmic ability to flag up
riskier
inputs
for human approval
so you have a bifurcation so for 80 90
of your
workflow you're still benefiting from
the scale performance the cost
effectiveness of an algorithm but as
soon as something unusual is detected or
emotional language is detected and say
you know an application or something
then it's escalated so what you do there
is you have this interesting approach of
a hybrid
and i think that works really well as
well because you're able to
ex have a good story to explain to your
public your users and your regulators to
say
we're using technology because it's
efficient
but we can catch a good number of risky
cases
and escalate them to humans so i think
that's worth thinking about as well
um
fantastic um i think that's come up to
the hour i i thought the discussion was
really really interesting um and thanks
to everyone who's raised questions um
you know we can have this discussion um
for longer and i think it does work
better when we're all around the table
with pens and paper
so maybe one day in future we'll be able
to do that but i'd like to thank
everyone for taking part in what i think
is an important
area um
making sure that the the systems that we
develop and design are safe fair and
ethical so
thank you for joining in
yep uh thank you tariq thank you
everyone
uh and uh um again please uh you know uh
thank our speaker by tweeting to him
uh details are in the chat
fantastic well have a great conference
there it looks like a really great
schedule thanks very much